me trying to become a partner at a big
law firm this little maneuver is going
to cost us 51 years
meme review
meme review trademark of pewdiepie all
rights reserved all right now that the
american government is boring again
dangers of a possible russian attack
thousands of troops to the border
well at least from a legal perspective
let's get back to a good old-fashioned
legal meme review
listening to two pro se parties argue in
open court they're just like they're
puppets or something so pro se litigant
is someone who doesn't have a lawyer and
i have been in so many different court
hearings where
because the judge is you know hearing i
don't know
10 or 20 or 30 different hearings in
that morning
you kind of have to wait for your turn
and the pro se litigants are always just
insane they just
don't know what they're doing they're
not trained as lawyers and so yeah the
the puppets arguing over nonsense uh and
the caption yeah the judge is going to
definitely side with you now that's it's
extremely accurate
uh law school graduates enjoying their
lives with the grim reaper bar exam
knocking on their door
oh boy that that brings me back that
really brings me back the thing is with
law school um you go to there for three
years the third year probably is not
necessary at all and uh then you
graduate and then you have to take the
bar exam um often you
don't have any money the law school
loans run out at the end of your your
last semester
and unless you got a cushy big firm job
you might not have very much money to
actually study for the bar over the
period of three to four months before
you take the bar exam so
yeah um it's a it's a really it's a
tough time and man
um the bar exam studying is no joke it
really does sap up every ounce of
of your will to live hello darkness my
old friend
what your coffee preparation says about
the type of law you practice civil
litigation corporate transactions so it
took me a second on this one um first of
all like the corporate transactions
getting the really nice coffee maker
that makes sense litigation i think this
would be funnier if it was just like
15 cups of coffee
uh because like the in-house is not
going to be doing very much no offense
in-house lawyers you do you do good work
but you do a lot less than the civil
litigators the civil litigators should
just have like
cups and cups of espresso um because you
know we're working basically all through
the night all the time
me trying to become a partner at a big
law firm this little maneuver is gonna
cost us 51 years
okay
this is funny probably only to me and a
handful of people in big loss so all
right how do i explain this big law
tends to be very prestigious it tends to
be very well paying
however it takes a really long time and
a whole lot of work to become partner in
a big law firm it varies some of the
smaller big firms
you can become partner in six to ten
years in some of the bigger big firms uh
you might get in after 12 to 14 years if
you're lucky and a lot of these huge
firms have up and out where if you don't
make partner on whatever track they have
say it's after 10 years
you just you don't get in you will never
become a big firm partner and some of
these big firms
let in
like eight people into their partnership
a year um it's it's a
don't get me started about this anyway
if you screw up one thing and you're on
the partner track it's gonna cost you a
lot of time potentially and this
interstellar clip uh
then it might cost you 51 years
dang it really does feel like that uh
for for some of these firms
me going into the dock to turn off track
changes and add oxford commas without
the partner's knowledge
so
microsoft word is extremely pervasive in
the big firm world and
for some reason some of those partners
out there don't use oxford commas
they're wrong they should be ostracized
but
look sometimes they are the boss and you
have to do what they say
so it is a very uh enterprising young
associate who goes in
without tracking the changes to change
things to an oxford comma hoping that
the big firm partner doesn't notice what
you have done i very much support that
decision because
an oxford comma is
everyone knows it the the right way of
doing things
live look at class action attorneys
after reaching a settlement
yeah so
how do i say this without offending
everyone um
when you have a big class action verdict
or a big settlement there's a lot of
money because you're aggregating lots
and lots of small claims so a claim that
might be only 20 if you aggregate it
among a million different class
members well that's 20 million dollars
and
the people that really benefit from that
are of course the class-action
plaintiffs attorneys um because they're
going to get a chunk of that maybe 30 of
that that chunk
now i happen to think class-action
lawsuits are very important it really
does make sure that um you know the
violators of these laws whether it's a
big corporation or whatever
they actually do follow the law because
otherwise there would just be a whole
bunch of small
uh infractions that no one would have an
incentive to take to court so class
actions serve a very important purpose
that doesn't mean however that the class
action attorneys don't make a huge
amount of money when they get a nice fat
settlement
there should be law school classes about
how to explain things clearly in
non-legalese to clients amen to that i
mean well frankly you know i made an
entire youtube channel devoted to
basically exactly that so you know if
you're having trouble explaining
something to your client just you know
send them to legaleagle they'll they'll
tell you uh
the non-legalese way of thinking about
these things
okay going to tell my kids this was
supreme court justice sonia swordfield
neil gorsuch
the current controversy
there is reporting that neil gorsuch
refuses to wear a mask around sonia uh
sotomayor uh despite the fact that um
she has some pre-existing conditions
but uh yeah you can definitely feel
some non-amused vibes coming from uh
sofia vergara here that's probably what
sonia sotomayor is is thinking uh even
though she wouldn't she would never
vocalize it
95 of lawsuits end up getting settled
like i'm gonna pay you a confidential
son to [ __ ] off
yeah well yes on tv you see the harvey
specter's in front of a jury basically
every day of the week and twice on
sundays that is not reality it's
actually more like 98 of all cases
settle before getting to trial and yeah
i bet a good number of those are in fact
confidential and a lot of those are for
nuisance value um as this is hinting at
in a uh not particularly discreet way
you're just paying off nuisance value
because it's not worth hiring an
attorney to defend or whatever and it's
just cheaper to pay him off
kid thinking of going to law school if
you're so against it then why'd you do
it me you know i'm something of a idiot
myself ah
i loved law school i really did i had a
great time it's not for everyone if you
don't know what you want to do with your
life do not go to law school if you know
for a fact you want to be a lawyer law
school is probably for you and you might
enjoy it too but look there's a lot of
stress
but uh i don't think anyone uh is an
idiot for for going to law school for
the right reasons
lawyer this lawsuit has a 50 success
rate client then do it twice
it do be like that sometimes it'd do be
like that sometimes
you're getting a raise oh my god
partnership the msj we just got served
with
all right msj is motion for summary
judgment and as we talked about before
it's really hard to make partner it's
very easy to get served with a motion
for summary judgment that is like a
trial on paper you're taking all the
evidence and you're saying uh even if
you assume all of the evidence is true
i win and of course the defense
attorneys are going to have to defend
against that and it takes a lot of work
to
fight a motion for summary judgment so
yeah i feel for pam here and in fact
i think
i think the first four christmases i
ever worked at a big firm i was
defending against emotion for summary
judgment as you become more senior you
lose less of your vacation time to
having to do the grunt work but i have
definitely put in my fair share of
responding to motions for summary
judgment
okay my law professor's reading my final
exam answers i think i have to turn the
sound on on this one
stupid song yeah yeah all right that's
uh exactly what i thought it was
so biden should not have been saying
that to the press
it was wrong when trump did it it's
wrong when biden did it i will say
though now that i have been a law
professor at georgetown for a couple of
semesters
there is there is some truth to this
oh poor law students
all right me giving legal advice me
living my life
yeah look i'm uh i'm indochino on the
streets and i am uh i'm mack weldon in
the sheets
what's something that you started doing
during quarantine but want to continue
doing after it's over asking people to
mute themselves
amen man yeah especially opposing
counsel
especially opposing council
all right the associate who put in their
two weeks notice when they're asked to
do any work i miss the part where that's
my problem
oh boy man
so in the big firm world the churn rate
is very high and once you put in your
two weeks notice
just good luck trying to get that
associate to do any work whatsoever
a friend just received an email with a
poop emoji from opposing counsel this is
why we went to law school i guess what
oh man uh i have never received a poop
emoji from opposing counsel i've never
sent a poop emoji to opposing counsel
you should have a reasonable amount of
decorum with opposing counsel if for no
other reason then your correspondence is
going to end up in front of the judge
and you want to put your best foot
forward that's real dumb you should not
do that
when the judge clowns you and everyone
including your client starts laughing
look
the judge is the king or queen of the
kingdom here and
if they start clowning you you just sit
there and you take it and you say yes
sir may i have another
thank you sir i have another cause
there's nothing that you can do and
actually if you're client to smart
you laugh at the judge's jokes there's
just
there's no way around it
thank you sir i have another
her i bet he's thinking about other
women him no interest is good unless the
most best if at all no later than 21
years after some life and being at the
creation of the
that is the rule against perpetuities
there that is the hardest thing to learn
in your property law class um it
i've done a video on this in the past
it's not worth going into it's about
limits to how long after you die you can
control
what the interest uh is doing because
otherwise we'd have
to deal with probate
decades and decades after um someone
dies and you're dealing with their will
um this is funny only to law students um
just consider yourself lucky if you
don't understand this joke
okay walking out of court after opposing
counsel said you would never win and
then you won
that's happened to me a few times
opposing counsel can be so full of
themselves and then
you just win and you just walk out like
you're you're the king of the world
there
yeah it feels good it feels real good
and if you do really well in trial you
might end up in morning brews newsletter
which is today's sponsor i've actually
been subscribed to morningbrew for
forever it is one of my absolute
favorite newsletters and it's awesome
that they wanted to sponsor this channel
morning brew if you didn't know is a
free daily newsletter delivered monday
through sunday it gets you up to speed
on business finance tech and law in just
five minutes and provides a fantastic
quick summary of the most important
issues while being witty irreverent and
informative and did i mention it's
completely free it tells me how much my
stocks are going up and how much
everyone else's crypto is going down
this week for example i learned that no
prime minister of pakistan has ever
completed a full term in office elon
musk won't be joining twitter's board
and got really interesting updates about
ukraine it's basically exactly the mix
of news that i'm actually interested in
the stuff that i didn't know i wanted to
know about and it's all written in a
hilarious style the morning brew is one
of the few emails that i actually look
forward to and open in the morning so
legal eagles this one is a complete
no-brainer morning brew is completely
free it takes less than 15 seconds to
subscribe so just click on the link
that's on screen right now or in the
description to get morningbrew for free
and not only will you get a newsletter
that you will actually read but you'll
actually help out this channel too so
click on the link that's below to get
morningbrew right away and while you're
there click on this playlist with all my
other real law reviews and legal
reactions so click on this playlist or
i'll see you in court